let's talk about how the cold war
between saudi arabia and iran is running
hot
these two really don't like each other
you called
the ayatollah khamenei the new hitler of
the middle east
if you want to look for a threat you
look at saudi arabia
they've been going at it in one way or
another for a long time now
nobody's winning hearts and minds it's
really coming at the expense of
ordinary middle easterners
so why can't iran and saudi arabia get
along what's this modern-day cold war
mean for the rest of us
and what do other countries like the u.s
and russia have to do with it
saudi arabia and iran are undisputed
heavyweights in the middle east
and when one of them lands a punch we
all feel it
some say it's a fight for regional
dominance political and economic
others say they're challenging each
other to be seen as the leader of the
muslim world
even though most muslims don't live in
the middle east they each represent a
different sect
sunni in saudi arabia shia and iran this
is part of the competitive dynamic
between the two
where both states actually very much
rely on
religious legitimacy as a pillar of
governance
saudi arabia is home to mecca and medina
the two holiest
sites in islam the saudis also host the
hajj pilgrimage
so that gives them power and standing
the kingdom's dominant form of sunni
islam is wahhabism
which is a strict and orthodox
interpretation its followers consider
the shia heretics
both the saudis and the iranians though
are accused of exploiting those
religious divisions
one example is what happened a few years
back
about 10 to 15 of the saudi population
is jia
they often say they're oppressed
and in 2016 a well-known shia leader and
critic of the saudi monarchy nimr
al-nimr was executed
his crimes included terrorism
iran condemned his killing and a crowd
set the saudi embassy on fire
the post-revolutionary regime in iran
has
promoted xiao religion and tried to
challenge
saudi religious authority what they're
really competing for though
is influence and the iranians seem to
have the upper hand when it comes to
military alliances in the region
in lebanon there's hezbollah a militia
with a political wing
funded by iran hamas and the gaza strip
also gets iranian support
in syria and iraq there are forces
backed by the iranian revolutionary
guard
and there's a reason why iran's taken
that approach it just doesn't have as
big an army as the us and saudi arabia
you might have heard the name kasim
suleimani he was the iranian general
credited with developing iran's
guerrilla-style operations abroad
the americans assassinated him a year
ago
tehran has become very skilled in
its low-cost opportunistic foreign
policy
riyadh hasn't developed a very robust
toolkit regionally so let's bring back
that map
where are the saudis well one place
they're in is yemen
fighting houthi rebels who as it turns
out are also backed by iran
and the war in yemen has really heated
up the saudi iran rivalry
the houthis attacked saudi oil
facilities and there have been
explosions on oil tankers
iran's been blamed but they deny being
involved
and what happens in those shipping lanes
of the gulf and red sea
is felt by everyone because it affects
the price of oil
the waters of the red sea are absolutely
crucially important for the oil price
and the delivery of millions of barrels
of oil every day
iran has made some other powerful
friends like russia and china
they're investing a lot in iran in its
ports and military and doing business
at a time when iran's economy has been
under sanctions
the saudis have plenty of friends too
countries in the gulf
sudan egypt even israel to some extent
their trump card though is the u.s they
both can't stand iran
but that wasn't always the case
back in the 50s iran and the us bonded
over a coup
that got rid of iran's prime minister
and strengthened the monarchy under the
shah
some say that's when saudi arabia began
seeing iran as a competitor
the shah of iran was trying to rapidly
modernize the country and
if not westernize the country and so
there was also
uh tensions of competition that began to
play out
but then the islamic revolution
the happened was replaced by a powerful
shia cleric ayatollah khomeini
and the balance of power in the region
tilted away from the americans
it's a really important starting point
for the obvious reason that the monarchy
was replaced by
a revolutionary islamic government
their relationship only got worse from
there iranian students took
52 americans hostage at the u.s embassy
in tehran
and don't forget iraq invaded iran with
saudi and american help
but where the iranians failed to hang on
to their american friends
the saudis succeeded despite some
serious strains
like how the saudis didn't back the u.s
invasion of iraq
how 15 of the hijackers behind the 911
attacks were saudi
and how the saudi crown prince was
linked to the dismemberment of
washington post columnist jamal
khashoggi
so how did the alliance survive well it
might have something to do with the
saudis buying more weapons from the u.s
than anyone else
the united states is also saudi arabia's
second largest trading partner
and the americans buy a lot of saudi oil
and then there's iran's nuclear program
the saudis are worried about iran's
potential to build a bomb
so the kingdom is building its own
nuclear research facilities
and has been accused of buying atomic
weapons from pakistan
something they both deny and remember
the iran nuclear deal
well it was about countries like the us
and russia as well as the eu
monitoring iran's nuclear program in
exchange for lifting economic sanctions
but saudi arabia felt it didn't go far
enough the u.s under president donald
trump
felt the same he pulled out of the deal
in 2018
now though joe biden is expected to try
to patch things up with iran and
renegotiate
the saudis aren't impressed neither are
the israelis
and in november the man seen as the
father of iran's nuclear program
was assassinated iran blamed israel
which neither confirmed nor denied it
was involved
our long-standing policy is not to
comment on such things so i'm not going
to do that now
so you'd think that with such an intense
rivalry saudi arabia and iran would have
gone to war already
but neither side seems to want that
there's a chance of something happening
always
i don't think that there is a high
chance of a direct war between tehran
and riyadh
had that been the case we would have
seen it in 2019.
what's kind of surprising is saudi
arabia and iran
actually have stuff in common they're
big oil exporters
they say they're champions of the
palestinian cause and they both want to
modernize their economies
those are good starting points to work
together but right now
they're indeed
[Music]
we hope that was a useful primer to
understanding what's going on between
saudi arabia and iran but there's a lot
more on aljazeera.com
so make sure to subscribe to our channel
or page wherever you're watching this
video to get the latest news
i'll see you next week